human beings are trapped in as Spiritual
Beings they're trapped this is what I
believe the spiritual being is trapped
in a body I believe I'm a spiritual
being Not a Human Being the spiritual
being would have tremendous potential
unbelievable potential it would be the
light on the candle not
the case the body would be the candle
and the spiritual being would be the
flame I'm the flame and I want to see
how hot can I burn how far can I go how
much light can I bring the world how
much positive truth message can I bring
this planet how much more can I do and I
think the problem is people are settling
out with just enough pay the bills take
care of my family get my little box get
my little house put my little welcome
mat on the front put the little gate
around the yard we're all going to be
happy I don't want the box I don't want
one location I don't need to welcome
that I want to know the world I want to
travel the world I want to inspire
people in every language maybe at the
end of all this I just become
everybody's own that I never
had need motivation watch the top 10
with believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and this channel was created
to help you overcome the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you've got
Michael Jordan level Talent at something
so get ready to push the limits become
obsessed with success and change the way
you look at things with Grant Cardone
and my take on his top 50 rules of
success volume 4 to give you the
confidence motivation and belief that
you need enjoy
Rule Number Two Become obsessed with
success if you're a business owner you
have to see the future if you're an
entrepreneur you have to look forward to
into the future what's going to happen
next if you're driving a car it's
responsible to look ahead everybody
agree if you're skiing down a mountain
you might want to keep your attention
out in front of you if you're riding a
motorcycle
who might want to not pay attention to
right where you are but where you're
going
pay attention to the Future what dreams
and goals do you have that are more
important than the money you have invest
money to hit your targets quit telling
yourselves lies about money exchange
money the only purpose of money is to
exchange money for time and connections
the only reason you have money is to
exchange money for time and people
you need people folks
you need people man you're going to grow
your business with people people that
work for you and people that you sell
products to
so obsessed
with the idea of freedom and making a
difference that you will do anything
anything I'll go into debt I'll spend my
last dollar this is how you're going to
be successful folks I'll borrow money
from my mom I borrow it from my dad I
borrowed from from family members I'll
go raise money I'll go back on the
street corner I'll go sell t-shirts and
hats failure after failure I'm obsessed
so much with my freedom that I'm willing
to talk to people even if I'm an
introvert okay I'm willing to go talk to
old people if I'm young I'm willing to
go talk to young people if I'm old I'm
willing if I'm out of work I'm willing
to go take a dumb sales job just to get
my feet back underneath me
become so obsessed
then everybody's like
what's wrong with you man
you change it rule number three change
the way you look at things you gotta
change your friends whoa if your friends
you need to make these people your
friends
people that have time to get away people
that are working
people that are creating
surround yourself with people that are
doing things
that that are seeking to be better
I was I was hanging around people that
were destroying themselves every day
people that were criticizing others that
were successful that were wasting time
beautiful Rock
they weren't looking for anything
except how everybody else was wrong
how they had been wronged I know because
I was doing this
I spent all my time talking about
how the rich guy
there was had his kids in tennis classes
and golf classes and they had a boat and
they went skiing he was such a prick
and when reality sorry guys didn't mean
to hear that
when in reality she didn't hear that
when in reality I should have been
looking at this what did this guy do
create
a situation where he could pay for his
kids to learn tennis if they want to
golf
and skiing
I was asking the wrong questions
I would tell my 20 year old self change
the questions you're asking change the
way you look at things
quit being so resentful and hateful
you know quick quick get get your game
together dude rule number four get a lot
of attention my business is kind of
different I own a hair salon
um and I have started a brand for myself
and probably went about it the wrong way
I started it
um doing booth rental instead of
commission and in the business I'm kind
of maxed out at making as much as I can
make for the size so I know I need to
expand but I also know that I have to be
taken
serious as a woman and I feel like it's
a it's a difficult thing to do and I
don't want to do it the wrong way this
time so I don't really know how to be
taken seriously I'm petite I have blonde
hair I always have crazy fingernails or
sometimes it's purple sometimes it's
blue yeah
so I guess the question would be where
where do I go from where I'm at to get a
lot of attention I know I I think you
just got to get a lot of attention
you know everything the red the blue the
long nails the shortening anything that
gets attention like you have to get
people's attention you guys have to get
interesting
so again she doesn't like some of the
things I do I have to do that I believe
in my mind I have to do some of that to
capture attention whether that's true or
not true I don't know I don't know maybe
it's not true
you know I know this if somebody wants
to have a movie and it wants to be a
great movie at the theaters they got to
get a lot of attention to get somebody
to go to the movie you've got to be
willing to get people not to like you
and what does that look like you have to
be like just by promoting so much that
you irritate people like what does it
mean to get people not to like Rush
Limbaugh who's a pretty pretty divisive
guy
uh says uh
you know the people that love him listen
to him two hours a day and the people
that hate him listen to him for four
hours
people that hate him listen to him for
four hours a day
so I'm just saying everybody wants to be
liked yeah everybody wants to be the the
popular person you guys got to be
willing to tell people your hair looks
terrible oh I I mean I do I'm I'm
actually very very good at my job I just
don't know how to um take it take it to
the next level I guess maybe maybe I'm
scared or I have yeah what's your
website what's your Facebook
right there nope the One underneath that
see I don't have a picture of you so I'm
going to go is that is that you yes
or is that your kids
um that well there's a picture of me and
then it's my daughter yeah so I mean
I don't want to see your daughter right
now I want to see you right I have a
hair therapy page
um I don't it's under hair therapy yeah
I see hair therapy I see it right here
so so like right okay now we got the
dogs
she's a veterinarian right
so like okay now I got hair okay that's
good before and after round like like
you guys gotta like like get clear on
what the message is right she needs a
you need a personal you need a business
page
right the trick is you got to get
attention Elena just wrote a book called
build an Empire okay she has to get
attention for the book which means leak
out data about the book not about
anything else but that book what is it
what chapter What audio what am I
listening to why am I listening to it
what do I get out of it like constant
pushing into whatever you do with hair
therapy okay
and and it's a good good but but dinner
date but what do I do with the dinner
date yeah
see like you
did this is where everybody's like
when's enough enough man when do you
just enjoy yourself
I don't know I'm gonna enjoy myself when
I'm in a position to just enjoy myself
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five re-educate
yourself on money you live on an
economic Planet regardless of your race
regardless of where you came from
regardless of your religion you live on
a planet that has two things on it
gravity I can't fly
and I'm reminded every day of gravity
right or wrong every day today I'm
reminded I'm reminded of it so much I
don't even know that it's
more that I shouldn't be able to jump
seven feet
right
and number two
money every day you were reminded this
is a financial planning okay I got a
little credit I don't have any cash on
me today none because I'm a real estate
guy
real estate guys are always broke
okay but I got me a little card
I can use this to open boxes
and I can use it to buy a box
right see how many were told all credit
credit cards are bad how many been told
debt is bad how many been trained that
oh oh all debt is bad debt I got about
500 million dollars worth of debt I got
to tell you I love it almost as much as
my wife and kids
[Music]
I do love it man because it generates
income for me
[Music]
now I'm telling you all this to tell you
look you have been miseducated if you're
having trouble with money it is because
you have the wrong data
it's not because you're stupid it's not
because you're lazy it's not because you
have a bad job okay I've had all those
excuses
you have the wrong information the first
25 years of my life I use the
information that is being disseminated
by TV and mass media
save your money say yeah if you heard
that one
okay you were brought up on that one if
you were brought up poor middle class
say yay
no no you can't say it like that say it
like you're proud yes I'm with poor
say yay no no well you brought up poor
middle class
[Music]
I'm gonna tell you something it's going
to take you forever if you don't get
your freaking enthusiasm right look if
your poor admit it
but damn I'm poor and then hate it
because you shouldn't be if you're in
the middle by the way if you're middle
class and you've got three meals a day
you got a car out there you can make the
payments on you got a little education
that you think is worth something and
it's not okay
and you got a good mom and a good dad
and you were brought up in a good family
good for you but dude that don't pay the
bills rule number six never be satisfied
have you ever ask yourself dude when are
you going to make it are you do you ever
suffer from this idea that you could do
more than you're doing
and no matter how much people around you
love you or
oh you're doing great patching the back
you're doing phenomenal amazing I've
been told my whole life I was doing
amazing I remember being I was 29 years
old I was the leading salesperson where
I where I worked
I mean I wasn't the best salesperson I
was the best sales person about like
three or four people
breaking records doing stuff that had
never been done
everybody's telling me how great I was
and I was like I know I can do more
I don't know if that's suffering
suffering some kind of like mental
disease some kind of never satisfied
with I've heard all these people talk
about
I remember the guy said hey your
disappointments are your disappointments
in life are equal to your expectations
suggesting that you not have
expectations
if you lower your expectations then you
won't have disappointments I gotta tell
you man I mean I can't even make sense
of that I'm like I have to have
expectations of myself I know I can do
better I know I can do more so
if me having big expectations of myself
I mean I'm going to be disappointed from
time to time that's the way it's got to
be rule number seven learn about real
estate the one other thing that I would
tell my 20 year old self look I own
seven businesses
and I would not tell you I would not
tell the 20 year old Grant to go get six
six businesses I would tell him
to learn everything you can about real
estate
everything real estate is the business
that's allowed me to go on these
magnificent trips that I'm taking my
family on I've been in business
myself for 30 years
okay six businesses do not
businesses combined do not allow me to
go on these trips it is the real estate
by and of itself
that's allowed me to take my wife and
kids
employees Partners friends on these
magnificent trips rule number eight get
to the top of the food chain when you're
hanging from somebody in your same space
right or they're hating on you remember
this you keep focused on creating
massive massive success
okay because
when you get up to the top of the food
chain whatever the food chain is in your
space whether it's Financial or
insurance or real estate or influencers
or podcasters or maybe you're doing a
real business you're not doing it you're
not an influencer and you're not a
podcaster you're like why all these guys
spending all this time doing podcasts I
got a business to grow I got employees
maybe you're doing that
so
what's my point
anytime you watch any of my videos you
say dude what's the guy really talking
about
I'm doing this for you I don't get paid
to do it
so if you're getting any value out of
this I'm telling you when you get up the
food chain and you will because you're
watching it you will get up the food
chain you will become a super successful
person but you won't if you hate
you will not become super successful
if you take the time
to worry about these other people in
your space flowing Power Man
love on them
send them love send them customers send
them deals but don't be surprised
when they don't send it back
because they're not
no book
tells you this all these guys doing
their little quotes talking about
abundancy scarcity but watch how they
act when you get up there man watch it
man it's gonna be crazy you're gonna be
like Cardone told me
while Rings now
they do tell me
that they were gonna hate on me I had I
had somebody call me the other day and
said hey dude I want to give you some
you need you need to know how to handle
some of these situations you're running
up against okay because there's a way
for you to prevent some of this
some of this these people hating on you
I said dude I don't I'm not going to try
to prevent somebody from being stupid
that's just dumb I got enough Insurance
in my life already
most of the time the accident never
happens the way to ensure that these
haters and criticizers and little
thinkers don't bother you is don't be
them number one number two
keep flowing them loving power baby
number three number three number three
get to the top
get to the top of the food chain
where everybody at the top knows you
and the people that wouldn't flow you on
the way up
or wish they didn't do what they did
okay rule number nine quit making sense
of the failures who's held a fight last
night
just goes to show you man you can't take
eight months off eight months of
drinking and showing off and bragging
and running your mouth
you can still get cracked
you got you know huh
yeah too many days off man too many days
off got to pay the price every day folks
otherwise you lose
period you will get beat you're going to
get beat in the marketplace if you don't
train every day I'm wearing my Cardone
University t-shirt
because if you don't train every day
don't expect to make the sale
if you don't train every day when you
leave here do not expect your people to
follow up if you don't train every day
do not expect your people to answer the
telephone correctly if you don't train
every day do not expect your people to
be motivated to do the right thing if
you don't train every day if you don't
require training every day if it's not
mandatory every day you will not get the
cash flow
you will get just enough money to pay
the bills and by the way everybody's got
that figured out everybody on the planet
has figured out how to pay their bills
even people that don't have any money
are figuring out how to eat everybody
agree so don't be bragging about your
bicycles and your two BMWs in your
country club that you paid for and the
roof over your head and you pay your
utilities and your gas and don't tell me
that all somebody else has got it worse
than you of course somebody else has got
it worse than you I hear this all the
time from people okay somebody gets
whacked they have a bad situation and
they're like but I'm grateful well you
mean you're grateful man you're filing
bankruptcy I know but I still got my
health
but you don't have your Financial Health
you shouldn't have gone bankrupt you
should have prepared for it don't make
sense of the failure okay if you're
taking notes quit making sense of the
failures rule number 10 get cash flow I
want to talk to you about the cash flow
I'm talking about the cash flow not the
snow I'm talking about getting that
third flow you work your wife works yeah
y'all cracking some freaking smack daddy
money you getting some long green you
made your first million dollars last
year that's right between the two of you
after you paid your taxes you end up
with four or five maybe six hundred
if you know how to play the game but
what you don't have is number three
your cash don't work you got scared once
you put away your first Milli you and
the wife are like oh no what do we do
now you called your uncle not me not
Uncle G you called your other Uncle the
confused Uncle he said pay the house off
you called your financial advisor start
investing in 401ks in the IRAs
and then you saw something I said about
cash
is trash
a home is dumb Equity what are you doing
folks get that third flow it's like a
good snowstorm baby you need that third
flow when you can't work you can't crank
you can't create
the third flow of income is the one you
buy you take your dead money cash is
trash take that dead money and get an
invested hard assets
and only make a decision to invest in
those things that pay you cash flow
you invest cash you get back cash every
single month rule number 11 push
yourself
he said he was the greatest I
graded he said that before he got in the
ring
I know a lot of you out there think
you're like I am the greatest but but
dude you ain't the greatest you're out
there like I'm living the dream you
ain't living a dream not in the dream
you're living so when you're hearing
this and you're like man I like what he
just said yeah because you agree with it
or you needed it because if you agreed
with it that doesn't help you grow
things that I agree with do not get me
my growth growth is typically painful
it hurts doesn't feel good I have to
push through it right think about the
tree roots growing they're having to
push through cement probably doesn't
feel good
so are you pushing through cement are
you getting that extra segment in are
you doing this every day you know are
you pushing for the sale if you can't
push yourself how are you going to ever
push somebody else in the completion of
an activity in the successful completion
of an activity is where ladies and
gentlemen you will find yourself rule
number 12 get addicted to productivity I
don't end up doing things that are
destructive when I'm busy doing things
that are constructive the truth is I was
never a drug addict
just had too much free time and made bad
choices this planet is filled with bad
choices pornography strip joints casinos
if you were filled up all day long with
activities if you were addicted to
productivity if you were junkied out on
potential
you wouldn't have time for all the other
garbage I would I wouldn't be I wouldn't
spend money on stuff I don't need when
is that money spent when do we waste
most of our money on this planet during
the holidays when we have free time when
do you spend your money when do you go
in debt on the holidays free time so if
I can just stay busy if I can use time
and create time how do I create time I
have 24 hours and I'm like I'm a jam as
much in those 24 hours as I can and then
I'll let you worry about me burning out
because that's what I'll hear next
what about burnout when you you're going
to burn out look I'm 60 years old
the more I do the more I can do and the
younger I get the more I do the younger
I feel the more I do the younger my body
feels I'm not going to burn out I'm not
a candle I'm Not wax rule number 13 show
up oh hey hey a lot of people talking
about showing up
some people denigrating denigrating on
my showing up rule it is ladies and
gentlemen not 80 percent of success
regardless what anyone tells you
it is probably more like
99.9 of success
and anybody that says otherwise
I'm just trying to get some attention
unnecessarily because I already love all
you guys check it out like if you don't
show up you have no chance of anything
happening and once you show up
physically show up
then you got a chance of the rest of you
showing up and you being freaking
unbelievable Superstar but if you don't
show up for the audition
sales call to speak too big
whatever it is you don't show up for
work man I think if you don't show up
and buy that lottery ticket You Can't
Win It
then you got to get a little lucky then
you got to persist then you got to do
all the other things you got to do but
first you've got to show up rule number
14 don't let others label you look man
I've been labeled OCD ACD compulsive
obsessive Cod bipolar you know they
wanted to put me on lithium Prozac all
this medication okay I mean real real
like serious drugs I'm not talking about
smoking weed on the weekends and that
was supposedly to handle my energy
are my creativity or uh the fact that I
didn't like sitting in a chair for 45
minutes at a time in school listening to
a history class of something that
happened 300 years ago that had nothing
to do with me when I'm sitting there
saying Hey listen I just want to learn
how to make some money man so you know
it's finally when I quit letting
everybody all these average people label
me and said you know what I'm going to
take this obsessive compulsive this this
whatever this energy is
has been you know made Wrong by Society
I'm gonna take this energy and I'm not
going to suppress it anymore and I'm
going to use it so for all the kids all
the kids out there teenagers that are
being mislabeled Millennials Millennials
a label man introvert is a label lazy is
a label nobody's lazy nobody is Born
Lazy these labels are being given to
people incorrectly and the truth is
nobody's actually lazy okay you're not
born lazy you're made lazy you're
allowed to be lazy you're encouraged to
be lazy you're surrounded by a bunch of
people that are lazy and then you become
lazy people that are being labeled OCD
ADD ADHD I think they're Geniuses it's
waiting for you there's this big gift
sitting there waiting to Bubble Up don't
medicate it and don't push it down give
it a voice Let It Be greatness and
genius rather than something bad rule
number 15 take responsibility the
president of Mexico
was on the phone with me today
now that is so cool look no I'll tell
you what it was because I've been making
decisions to change my network
I'm tired I'm tired I I overnight I am
sick and tired
of
the same group
that
maybe for whatever reason they're just
not happy with something I did
and oh he did that and he did this and
he said that and I didn't like that and
but dude I'm like okay I don't want to
play big games I need a new story right
so I made the decision I went on the
chalkboard and started saying new
friends new network don't complain about
them they are where they are it's not
anybody else's fault no whatever I'm
getting in mind with us we're not
satisfied with that game
because everybody else is hanging around
those people they're fine they're all
having a good time and I'm the one
disappointed so I'm the one that has to
go to the white the chalkboard and map
out oh I need a new network it's not his
fault
it's not don't be disappointed with Kim
I need to change nobody else in the
world needs to change
and so ever since I was 25 years old
when I went to a treatment center and
and had to confront my drug addiction
the one thing I learned there that was
so valuable was you have you are
responsible then they confused me with
you're responsible but it's not really
your fault because you got a disease I'm
like which one is it am I responsible or
do I you know and I chose to say hey
it's not the deceased I I am responsible
and I haven't used drugs for 35 36 years
so
um super well done now I need to apply
that same that same calculation to oh I
want to change my network on the phone
with the president
of Mexico rule number 16 Master sales
you need to learn how to communicate
with people
okay the the the the the site here says
the PowerPoint says learn to become a
professional salesperson when when I
know when I think of the professional
salesperson I think about a professional
communicator
someone know who knows how to make
contact
someone who knows how to control the
conversation I don't think about a
swindler I don't think about a tricky
dude I don't think about a huckster I
don't think about a scam artist I think
about
dude this guy showed me something I
didn't know you have any things that I
almost bought were the wrong thing but a
professional salesperson with a full
pipeline said no no you don't want that
one of the best salespeople I know okay
a guy named Robert I'm not going to give
his last name because I don't have
permission I'm sure he wouldn't mind 25
billion dollars worth of real estate hey
Robert is this a good deal
yeah you know but that's not the one I
would do I would buy this one over here
if I were you okay
see he's a professional he's a
communicator he'll tell me what I'm
doing wrong he'll tell me when I'm right
tell me when I'm wrong he'll challenge
me he's not playing games trying to like
match tones I saw this video the other
day matching people so did you see it
okay get
right at the right moment
at the right moment
lower your voice and I don't want to do
that I'm talking about a professional
salesperson it doesn't have to rely on
tricks because their pipeline's so big
there's seven billion people on the
planet that are qualified and interested
in buying your product you do not need
to trick people and that's why so many
people think commission I don't want to
be a salesperson equals I don't want to
be a huckster well you don't have to be
if you're a professional rule number 17
be obsessed with success my mother was
there for me when I didn't need her to
be there for me okay okay she didn't she
never let me down but but that doesn't
mean she pushed me up
you understand the difference my mom was
a great mother she was always there for
me it didn't mean she pushed me up to
the next level though because every time
I went to my mom and said Mom let me
tell you what I'm doing
be like that's awesome but just son
remember I love you just the way you are
how many of you have a parent that will
tell you that just remember
she would still tell me that she's 70
she was 78 at the time she's like just
remember
thank you
I love you just the way you are you've
done enough wins enough Grant you're
doing fine Grant I love you just the way
you are love yourself the way you are
man I'm like but I don't
I can't lie to myself I do not love this
no my I don't Chuck knows what I'm
talking about Chuck hates himself
Chuck knows he can do more
am I right Chuck
and then he's trying to communicate that
to his wife or his wife to get it and
his wife is like Chuck what's wrong with
you are you broken Chuck you need
purpose
okay and then he's gonna go see the
therapist like I did and the therapist's
gonna be like oh yeah you got add
you got that the OCD you got the the the
OPD you got the OCD ACD
[Music]
you know
you know I said no I got the the the uh
the o s d I'm obsessed with success
disease
I'm obsessed
and I want my damn 200 back don't tell
me I'm add I'm taking offense to that
okay I don't add I multiply
I'm trying I'm trying to figure out how
to run 70 businesses and have 70 000
employees I'm not worried what you
worried about you're worried about how
many browsers I got open in my mind rule
number 18 study the one percent the
people that operate this planet the
handful the one percenters have
different information than you have
okay they're not talking about going to
college
they're not talking about saving money
[Music]
you don't hear wealthy people talking
about I need to buy a house
[Music]
Warren Buffett you know Warren Buffett
Warren Buffett's not like I need to buy
a house
I have to have a home to live in Warren
Buffett bought one house his whole life
he never talks about it
what's eBay
he's buying businesses what's he
investing his money in businesses right
he's not buying a house where money dies
rule number 19 invest when Steve Jobs
died
when Steve Jobs died where did his money
come from
one place was Apple he owned some Apple
stock but that was not the majority of
his wealth majority of Steve Jobs wealth
when he died
was from no iTunes is Apple
nope
it was an investment
uh look it up uh what's the name of the
company uh everybody's going to know the
name of the company oh Pixar Pixar Pixar
Pixar he owned he he was he was one of
the found three founders of Pixar
that's where most of his wealth was from
Investments so to get to the top of the
food chain you gotta to get to the
Legacy well to be able to leave your
family something which is really what
everybody wants to do no every once you
have the BMWs you have the BMWs once you
have the country club you have the
country club once you have the Gucci
belt you have the Gucci belt once you go
on a yacht trip you go on the yacht once
you fly first class well you've done it
even when you go out and buy your own
plane you've done it at some point
you're gonna be like okay now what now
what when do I start giving back you're
not going to give back to society until
you create indestructible wealth which
is really what everybody wants to do
everybody wants to give more and help
out more and make a difference rule
number 20 change how many of you want to
change
[Applause]
two things if you want to change
number one you gotta change
you want you want to change a little bit
change a little bit you want to change a
lot change a lot
[Music]
to change you got to change
and number two
you have to learn how to talk to people
you've got to learn how to communicate
you have to learn how to stand on a
stage and communicate maybe it's not
this stage
maybe it's not 35 000 people
maybe it's one person that's a stage
your house is the stage you're going to
talk to your spouse your business is the
stage you're going to be talking to the
treasury Department selling them stop
the madness
stop the madness we're not going to save
money here we're going to make money
here we're gonna go get money here
you're going to have a stage with your
lawyer your lawyer is going to say don't
do it stop the madness
you're a lawyer dude I'm running a
business tell me how we can do it
I don't ask lawyers in accountants for
business advice
record the data you're an accountant
do the job you're the lawyer
let me run the business into the ground
okay we're gonna run it into the ground
[Music]
we're gonna do it Grant's way
not the lawyer's way and not the
accountant's way
two things you got to do to change folks
you got to change and you need an
audience rule number 21 don't stay small
first thing you got to do is decide as a
business owner do I want to make more
money TC if this dude this dude with the
camera if he shot if his if his pockets
are empty he's walking around empty
pockets
and he's got his fancy camera this is
the the problem with the artist
they starve their whole life
they starve their entire life and then
and then you wonder why they're grumpy
there's no money I'm eating at Littles
all the time sooner or later sooner or
later you hit the reality he hits the
reality I got a nice camera I love
taking photos I got to shoot Grant
Cardone he watches Lord sugar leave on
his jet
and says hey why does he get to fly
free everywhere do whatever he wants and
I'm stuck with my camera and no money
how many believe that
later sooner or later after days of
going to work months ago into work years
ago into work sooner or later if he
works for this man he's like I resent
this man
I resent this man I resent that man
business owner I resent Paul McFadden
the business owner I resent you so I
know I won't work for you in fact what
I'm going to do is screw things up for
you
it's called disengagement the only
business people that will survive the
only entrepreneurs that will make it in
business are those people that decide to
grow their businesses little little
will fail
not the little grocery store
okay if you try to stay small if you try
to stay small
you will fail
okay I'm telling you this from personal
experience
I try to stay small
I tried to manage the business I tried
to be the king of the business I tried
to have no employees because employees
cost money I'm like I'm not going to
have any employees
I'm not going to pay the cameraman I'll
just hire him when I do a gig
and the next time I'll hire another guy
and that'll keep my expenses low how
many are brought up like this keep the
expenses real low where we can manage
the expenses the expenses are going to
be so small that that no matter how much
we make I keep it all rule number 22
brand and advertise you have to
advertise you have to advertise in your
career to blow your brand up you cannot
not advertise and save money it cost me
probably 400
[Music]
should I even say a number this big or
do I lose everybody no 400 million
dollars we have estimated is what it
cost me because I didn't advertise for
the first 20 years of my career but
before you spend one dollar in
advertising and and even if it was
wasted it'd be a great dollar to spend
even if you don't get a return you
should do it but before you do that what
you need to do is spend a lot of time
energy and resources on branding I made
a mistake here not spending more money
in advertising I made a bigger mistake
not spending more time energy and
resources on branding and you are making
a mistake if you do any kind of metrics
on did it convert did it pay off
branding will not pay off
zero you will get a zero return if you
don't brand
okay you will get a zero return for
Branding in the beginning you will get
you will never get a return on
Advertising if you don't brand branding
is a must it is senior to advertising
rule number 23 work on yourself you hang
around people that are changing will not
change you
I know this whole Mastermind thing we
have masterminds I believe they're great
they're awesome but if Ryan back there
hangs around me and I'm changing
that don't mean he's gonna change so
look I've seen this for 30 years
you know I've gone places where the the
only reason everybody went there was
because they were working on themselves
changing improving courses classes
education Elena and I actually great
story about Elena and I
the only reason people went to these
places was to improve themselves okay I
got to tell you something only about 10
of the people that went there
flew
they were changing they were actually
making the changes
the other people were hanging around
people changing just because you're
around people change it doesn't mean you
are gonna change you got to do the work
to change my brothers and sisters
you got to change
you know you know Ryan hangs around me
if I change my clothes that don't mean
he changes his if everybody in the house
changes their clothes takes a shower
put some deodorant it don't mean if Ryan
does not change his clothes and take a
shower and put on his deodorant he gonna
stank
dropping bombs to change you gotta
change it doesn't matter how many people
you hang around that are changing if you
if you hang around everybody just
getting rich getting wealthy doing great
creating stuff and you're not you're not
going to change to change
you got to change rule number 24 don't
listen to bad advice I heard a man tell
me once she's like grant money won't
make you happy I'm like son
so you ain't got any money
quit giving advice on something you
failed at
right if you're taking notes you want to
write this down never ever ever
take advice from a quitter never ever
take advice from a quitter
particularly Financial advice the first
question I asked you today was this do
you want to make more money
then quit taking advice from people
about money they don't have any money
rule number 25 set big goals this used
to be a goal of mine to make one million
dollars a year
that was my goal when I was 35 years old
one day I said to myself one day I said
self little g dog
little g dog one day young man I wrote
this over and over and over again I
talked to myself in the mirror I'd sit
on the toilet and say one day one day
I'm gonna I'm gonna make a million
dollars one day one day and people used
to tell me that's crazy dude
like why do you think so big this is
when people were telling me not to
they're like why do you need to do all
that why do you just be happy just be a
good person okay be happy that you live
in America and be happy that you have
meals and be happy you got good health
and all the things that the people
around you that quit on money that quit
on Financial Freedom that quit on
possibility that quit on their potential
all the things those people will tell
you
to try to convince you to quit
when in reality what they're really
trying to do is make sense of why they
quit
note to self
okay last month I distributed 1.2
million dollars to other people okay
it's not money I made it's money I sent
out so it just goes to show you how
small I was thinking when I was 35 years
old rule number 26 go where the money is
this is um at the Beverly Hills Hotel
today if you've never stayed here you
have to okay every single day that I
have been here I have met someone that
will help me in my career they don't
tell you this in school they don't teach
you this your parents didn't teach you
this you have to go where the money is
money is not just okay I'm gonna buy a
Lamborghini and I'm gonna buy a big
house and I'm gonna buy some jewelry and
I'm gonna get some nice sunglasses I'm
gonna go buy a big watch and I'm gonna
go on vacation it's about going where
other people are that have money and
that can help you
that can help you so you can help others
so you can help your parents so you can
take care of them
and take care of your kids so you could
be a good example look money's not going
to make you happy you guys already know
that everybody knows that I don't even
know why we're talking about money will
not make you happy
bad
okay
it'll get you an Uber
it'll get you an Uber it'll get you a
hotel room it'll get you access to the
Polo Lounge it'll get you breakfast this
morning to sit at the right place with
the right people that maybe someone
someone discovers what you're doing what
you're up to and that takes interest
every single breakfast every single
lunch that I've been here and every
single dinner that I've been sitting out
in public I have met someone that can
literally help me with my career Rule
Number 27 keep things simple do you want
to make your business bigger
I know this seems really simple
but the reality is if it's not simple
I don't care where you are on planet
Earth
whether you're in Wales
I'm going to go to Glasgow tomorrow
we're going to leave here and go into
Spain
I'm going to do Russia in about three
months I'm gonna go back to Miami and do
business in Miami no matter where in the
world I am folks if it's not simple
you're not going to make money
listen to what I'm telling you if it's
not simple you will not make money
over long periods of time it's got to be
simple for other people to understand it
rule number 28 invest a guy invests five
thousand dollars he's got five thousand
dollars in the bank another guy's got 50
Grand in the bank and another guy's got
500 000 okay all three of these people
invested money with me this is Cliff
this is Dave and this is Jennifer okay
Cliff sent me five grand dude it was his
last five grand it was as hard for him
to do this is this guy to do that do you
understand okay this guy earns I don't
know he's gonna earn 300 bucks a year
this guy's gonna earn three thousand
dollars a year this guy's gonna earn
thirty thousand dollars a year
but they all had to start with this
they all start with five thousand
dollars everybody starts with five
thousand dollars including Jennifer
right here she's got a five just another
zero
all of them had to make a decision
should I keep the money this is where
the opportunity comes in you got to
think in terms of opportunity costs okay
is my money better in the bank or is my
money better in an asset that add that
that can grow over time okay do I buy a
watch
okay do I buy something stupid
it is beautiful but it's stupid let's
keep it real
stupid is as stupid does and that ladies
and gentlemen is stupid Paddock
okay however
the reason the way I bought the paddock
was because the real estate that I buy
not this real estate okay I already
distributed these people the real estate
I invested in sent me a little check
check rule number 29 reach your full
potential how many heard this statement
before knowledge is power Warren Buffett
was on TV yesterday he's 88 years old
he's worth 83 billion dollars
okay I want to know where
where the guy is in his cycle
everybody's got a life cycle
I'm young I'm broke I get a little bit
of money I'm middle class now okay now
I'm rich now I'm super wealthy okay and
now I'm gonna die
my data points will change everybody
agree with that
where are you getting the data from okay
if this is probably where I'm at right
now in a number of places in my life
both my finances my brand recognition uh
my International presence my business
expansion I'm probably up on a upward
slope
I might be down here and not even know
it yet
okay because I might not know how high I
could go probably this is a mistake I
didn't know how big I could get
so
down here what am I telling you would
identity get your money saved
like if you go back and read my books
when I was 30 years old 35 years old and
done that save your money save all your
money save all your money why I'm trying
to put some money away
Then I then I get right here I'm like I
need to get the money to work
right I get here and I'm like I need to
get the people around me making money
when I'm starting this cycle so you need
to understand when you're listening to
me today
leave here and you go to to John
Maxwell's Workshop where is John in the
cycle of his life
the source of data
Steve Jobs Steve Jobs was down here
animal he was an animal him and Bill
Gates were like carnivorous
they they weren't thinking about giving
money away they didn't have any money
they were in a garage
right scrapping out man buying tacos
probably stealing a little bit
Warren Buffett Warren Buffett down here
took 500 shares of Ford Motor Company
stock for free to pitch it
to tell people I have 500 shares of the
IPO
in 1957 Ford Motor Company went public
he got 500 shares from the company to
say he was buying Ford Motor Company he
didn't buy a Ford Motor Company they
gave him the shares it's against the law
okay he's outside the statue of
limitations that's what he did then that
what he's doing now rule number 30
commit fully raise your hand if you've
ever given up before
giving up and quitting are very
different things
one you never try again the other you
might see it's possibility
if you refuse to give up I promise you
you will have a victory and when you do
you gotta get a Sweet Victory Day
most people are getting just enough to
compare themselves to be better off
than other people if you have desire in
your heart if you want to do better
you have to put your money your energy
where your commitment is rule number 31
get addicted to success they're gonna
tell you like they told me and I
believed it for a while I did but I
didn't is look you're a drug addict you
can't help it you're powerless
it's in your genetic code and you have
no control over it now I'm going to tell
you right now that I believe that to be
complete complete garbage emotion so
if I was a drug addict and it's
completely out of my control then I
would have had to use drugs today yeah
and I didn't so using drugs is a choice
yeah I would tell you and I would tell
everybody that that has that addictive
nature is congratulate yourself and pat
yourself on the pack that you have the
ability to be addicted to something yeah
and take that addiction dude and put it
into something unbelievable yeah because
every every super successful person that
I have studied and or met it is has the
ability to be obsessed with something to
the point of losing sleep yeah to the
point of I don't need to need to eat
I'll go in debt I'll go bankrupt I'll go
down with the ship to make this thing
happen and that's really what turned my
whole life around was just flipping the
addiction not trying to not be in
control not trying to turn it all over
just saying hey I'm gonna take this
energy and I'm gonna dump it into into
work rule number 32 I
think you gotta advertise and you gotta
spend money on marketing and advertising
if you if people don't know you it will
cost you a fortune it cost me 400
million dollars over the last 20 years
because I was not spending money in
marketing and promotion and advertising
and social media I actually thought
social media didn't work
[Music]
I was so wrong about that
I started a social media company where
we actually now run ads for companies so
that you get known the way I've gotten
known today with I don't know a million
1.4 million Instagram followers a
million subscribers on YouTube six
million people on Facebook trust me if
you don't advertise on social media
I would call you a dumbo you know why I
have the right to because I didn't think
it worked either rule number 33 take
care of you first all people men and
women they should be more greedy about
their personal
dreams
because I think Mom was five kids and
I've got this responsibility and yeah
you did but you also have responsibility
yourself like how can I if I can't take
care of me how can I take care of
somebody else yeah and this has always
been my battle cry like I have to take
care of me
you know and and how can I help anyone
I'm broken
I'm messed up you know I'm I'm I'm
coming out of a treatment center for
drug addiction I didn't need to help
anybody else I needed to get I needed to
get on Solid Ground you know and I
needed to make sure I wasn't going back
to treatment and then I needed to clean
up the mess that I mean I needed to do
this for me because
uh and that that has been my contention
now for many years like just keep slowly
taking care of your neighborhood until
you're in another zip code rule number
34 improve your network they say your
network equals your net worth your
ability to move this planet to change
things to get investors funding money is
determined by who you know if you got a
money problem I guarantee it's got
something to do with your network
okay if you if you're having marriage
problems I assure you would 100
certainty if you're having marriage
problems there's somebody in your
network
their beliefs in marriage problems if
you're having kidney problems you know
not kitty kitty now I'm talking about if
you've got problems with your kids it's
because your network is having problems
with chilling if you have a Time problem
I don't have enough time I can't find
enough time I'm working too hard I never
have time I can't find time to work out
I can't find time for the kids I can't
find time for the marriage you have a
network of people that have time
problems rule number 35 scale I thought
I thought people cost money
none of these people cost anything okay
do you know that only four percent of
companies in America make a million
dollars a year
67 percent of all companies in America
have no employees okay so if you stay
with no employees and you're the only
person working there promise you you
will not make money less than four
percent of all companies in America make
a million dollars a year rule number 36
think bigger when I was in McDonald's
and I got fired from McDonald's flipping
burgers are doing fries or what are we
doing whatever they had me do they had
me they had me do what you know there
this is what we do right it's a road
it's a factory
and um
I was 16 years old and and um my dad had
been dead six years so
like you know like I'm uncertain I'm 15
16. I've just had sex for the first time
dude everything is so complicated
making five bucks an hour that's one
whatever it was no it's probably like
280. wow
yeah but that wasn't that wasn't the
problem I was grateful for the 280. but
I was awkward I was not confident I
didn't know how to talk to people
um
you know I hated the job
but if somebody was to dude go learn
this game so you can own 50 McDonald's
restaurants like if I would have had
that that idea I bet you I would own a
bunch of McDonald franchises today but I
went there just for the 280. yeah not
not far hey I want to do something I
think I truly think that the the thing
that I've suffered from the most in my
life as I look at Kobe and you know all
these pictures of these great people you
know dude I just thought too small I was
worried about the 80 bucks
and I was worried about what the car
dealers thought about me that audience
rule number 37 focus on income not
expenses I was I was bi I was managing
the bottom half of my financial
statement not the top one inch today I
spend 95 percent of my time on the top
literally inch inch and a half
and I ignore the rest I might spend
three percent of my time on managing
expenses and costs and budgets I spend
95 percent of my time on the income of
the company
on how to increase the income
how to blow up the Top Line let's see if
they even let me in my office yeah how
to blow up the Top Line
in hopes that
I could spend more money in marketing
spend more money in branding spend more
money employees rule number 38 know your
strengths and weaknesses I don't think I
was built to be quiet like like they
tell you when you were growing up you
know be quiet be seen not heard or be be
hurt whatever the deal is you know don't
touch your own horn and don't get too
much attention and don't promote
yourself and
but look man God was a show-off man
look what he created
just didn't stop he's not quiet no okay
rainbows you know Sons planets like
waterfalls everything you're crazy man I
think we love people that are
grateful and have humility but we also
love to see people do great things yeah
is there a balance that they should have
like also be grateful and humbles as
opposed to kind of like the
McGregor uh dude I love McGregor yeah
see I like that that's your that's your
energy you like you're on that frequency
I I you know who doesn't like it dude
look at how big the audience is yeah you
know look at the Rock he doesn't have
little muscles right but he's got more
humility let's say oh he knows how to he
knows how to play that game oh my God I
mean there's nobody better than the
rocket that Obama was unbelievable at
that yeah it it staying connected that's
what I'm terrible at I'm awful at it I
am so bad at it why I don't know why
I I don't know why I I just know I'm bad
at it rule number 39 focus on the money
I don't want to talk to you about
execution and management and business
planning and culture I want to talk to
you about money because money we believe
is the number one problem in your
business
it's not Mission it's not purpose it's
not all these beautiful things everybody
tells you it's not planning and
organizing I have seven businesses
there's seven little companies there's
been no plan
there's been minimal organizing
tremendous speed
tremendous speed to Market okay is one
of the things that has made us
successful but mostly in all the
businesses every business was created
around the concept
it needs to make money
[Music]
because if it doesn't make money
you'll call yourself an entrepreneur
[Music]
because you're not gonna be able to call
yourself a business person
[Music]
and so this industry of entrepreneurs
that that is now so popular
I never even knew the term until like a
year and a half ago
okay before that I was in California
somebody said I was an entrepreneur uh
15 years ago I'm like well that that's
that's code for I don't have a job
okay today today look if you want to be
an entrepreneur good but really what you
want to do is evolve to being a business
person that makes money
and that provides a good living for a
lot of other people right so number one
problem in your business is employee
disengagement it's not actually money
is their problem
employee disengagement how many of you
here own a runner Department let me see
if you run or manage more than more than
just yourself let me see a hand
how many of you here run or manage a
household
okay good well if you can't manage the
household
by the way you have disengagement at a
household level would you agree husband
and wife are disengaged
one's doing their own plan this one's
doing their plan fifty percent of those
marriages are going to fail okay that's
what they say they're going to divorce
truth is way more than 50 fail people
should not be looking at the divorce
rate they should be looking at the
failure rate rule number 40 be a winner
there is no shortage of success
regardless of their culture race
religion economic background or social
group most people would agree that
success is vital to the well-being of
the individual the family unit and the
group and certainly to the Future
survival of all these things
look without success your group your
company your goals and dreams and even
the entire civilization would cease to
survive and thrive
winning over and over again at
everything in which you're involved
ensures you're going to be able to
further expand and survive and it
guarantees that both you and your ideas
Will Survive not just get by but survive
into the future
if you quit caring then you're going to
quit winning
and if you quit winning long enough in
this thing called success you're gonna
just plain quit
how would being successful be important
to you and how would it improve your
life look success is needed in order to
perpetuate to push forward people places
and things
you must never reduce success in your
mind or in a conversation to something
that doesn't matter on the contrary you
must treat successes though it's vital
it's important
anyone that minimizes the importance of
success to your future has probably
given up on his or her own chances of
accomplishment
and it's spinning now his or her life
trying to convince others you in this
case to also give up
individuals and groups must actively
accomplish their goals and Targets in
order to carry on with their goals and
targets if not look they'll either cease
to exist or be consumed and become part
of something else it's not enough just
to play the game it's vital you learn
how to win at this game rule number 41
be great at getting attention
when you're in front of a customer do I
have your attention
when you're getting attention you need
to know something else is trying to get
their attention too
you're in
your intition with everything and you
don't need to make attention you need to
get attention they're tied together
attention is money get it keep it
multiply it that means when I'm in a
meeting I need to get your attention I
need to get it I need to be sure I have
it I need to keep it and then I need to
multiply that attention because if you
don't keep my full attention you ain't
gonna get none of my money rule number
42 beat the Sun up Grant rant of the day
the one you need to live with wake up to
every day is that right there
okay beat the Sun up folks you gotta
beat the Sun up if you can't beat up the
roll-up of the sauna
you're gonna get beat up in life okay
I've been doing this for a long time now
I'd say beat That Thing Up that monster
out there that warms this planet that
nourishes and gives us light you can't
live it to next life if you're not
beating the Sun up so many of you
complaining about how much time you have
you don't have time man because you
don't beat the Sun up get started early
and when you get started early that
means you need to shut it down early
okay shut it down early so you get sleep
I was I was I was asleep last night at
nine o'clock so I could beat the Sun up
tomorrow this morning and see
the world wake up with me rule number 43
learn from everyone I don't I don't need
to spend time with a mentor I need to
study a handful of people that have
proven over time they were important and
and that they did something Walt Disney
he's a mentor of mine one guy almost
went bankrupt free time that is a
spiritual Adventure like like hey man
how do you do that how do you have a
dream Howard Schultz with Starbucks I
don't like his political viewpoints but
I do like the fact that no everybody
told him Starbucks was a bad idea he's
like yeah okay well whatever it's a
terrible idea Steve Jobs total Maniac
like neurotic I wouldn't do any of that
stuff but I do I do like the guy's
ferocious commitment so if I can take
Rob those pieces from different people
right and say hey man I want to be more
like that guy or that gal right you know
so so you know what I'm saying like like
that that that's my that's my deal like
how can I mix it up with Jared how can I
I'm interested in leaving something
last longer than I do rule number 44
grow from victories I know a lot of
people say they they learn from their
losses but I I don't I I learn I get
better because of my successes I don't
need a lot of kryptonite moments I'm not
interested in those yeah it just takes
longer to grow again yeah to get back to
where you want to be you know Mike Mike
told me something the other day in the
hot box he says you know because he
started thinking differently about some
of the stuff I was saying too
hmm
and he said I said you know Mike I know
you blame you know you think your
success is what hurts you but I
guarantee if you look back
those first fights you were winning
everything about everything brightened
up in your life when you started winning
in life he ran you know
my grades got better hmm
he's got more confidence dude of course
he even learned better I said you know I
I know I don't learn from the losses
I learned from successes and then I try
to repeat those things do more of those
things that are and then get the get the
get the get the the bucket gets bigger
yeah right the rim gets bigger the field
goal gets bigger right everything gets
bigger it's easier to make the shot
because I have the wins and I think it
it I feel so bad for people particularly
around money that they never have the
victories back to back enough victories
to be like wow what else could I do rule
number 45 get addicted to success when I
walked out of the treatment center the
counselor Phil I think his name is Bill
in the treatment centers you know you
you basically share all your secrets I
was telling like I want to be rich I
want to be famous I want to write books
and the guy's like dude if you don't
give up on all that [ __ ]
you will be back here in 30 days [ __ ]
because like you need to be satisfied I
never forget the speech on the 28th day
health insurance had run out so they're
going to kick my ass out right because
the money ran out he says if you don't
give up on all these ideas these these I
grand Grand Illusions the the
grandiosity you don't give up on all
that you will be that hated and I threw
all that addiction and that [ __ ]
obsession with destruction that you you
like understand as well as anyone and
they've talked about so eloquently
I threw all that obsessive energy into
work
to become a master at at a few things
and and that's what's really changed my
life and my direction to where I can
just run down a path and and over the
period of 35 years create something for
myself that you know I'm sitting in a
room with
it makes you obsessed rule number 46
study wealth 25 years ago
I had three friends
my life has not always been this I had
three friends
one was a drug dealer
one was my girlfriend who didn't love me
she loved the drug dealer more than she
loved me
she loved the drugs she's still on drugs
today
and my third friend couldn't be a friend
to himself much less to me
I had three friends in my entire life
I was the black sheep of my family
five kids
everybody in my household was worried
about Grant
everybody my two sisters my brother my
mother
were convinced I would end up in prison
or I would end up dead
I should not be here today
so at 25 I recommitted to my education
but this time I started studying not
things that were in books but people
that it actually created wealth not
people that it made money but people
didn't creative wealth this is
completely different I was no longer
studying accounting and economics I was
studying wealthy people and only wealthy
people I'm not talking about the doctor
that was a neighbor that makes a million
dollars a year and he's working 18 hours
a day and he hates his job
right he's working seven days a week he
can't ever spend time with his family
I'm talking about the yacht people I'm
talking about the people that are
spending as much time as they want on
vacation I'm talking about the car
dealer that had uh 28 car dealerships or
82 car dealerships that has indisposable
money and I quickly realized something
that the wealthy people
had Financial Freedom and no one else
did okay a very small percentage of
people lots of people have money my
uncle had millions of dollars he was
terrified about his money wouldn't spend
it acted like a miser buried money in
the backyard
I realized my parents had it wrong the
information I had that was wrong I
started comparing the wealthy people to
what my dad did my dad worked every day
every day of the week if he wasn't
working at the office he was working in
the yard they saved money they cut their
own grass okay we ate all our food we
turned the lights off we didn't waste
anything
and that was uncertainty it was
insecurity and it was fear and it
perpetuated uncertainty insecurity and
fear and and all the lessons about money
money doesn't grow in trees a penny
saved is a penny earned eat all your
food people are starving okay money
money you don't waste it don't play with
it all that creates insecurity and it's
incorrect rule number 47 be persistent
once I decided I'm going to do something
it's like
there's no let the the chances of me
letting go is something that's important
to me
a friend like I am either the best or
worst friend a person has
why so because because like if if you
and I are in a club and something goes
down I will be there
swinging it out okay I have no chance of
winning the fight I can only be a
distraction to the thing throwing a
bottle but you're not going to see me
just run yeah right so so
um
and I'm not going to run for my dreams
like I'm not going to run for my kids
I'm not going to run for Milena I'm not
gonna there's nothing Elena could do to
cause me to like run away from her rule
number 48 expand your network I get
comfort and nurture from them when I
fail that's not what you need you need
to expand your network when I was
getting comfort from the people that
love me and accepted me as I was I
should have been expanding my network by
investing in conferences Summits and
masterminds to get access to the way
other people think the way other people
operate and to their success so I could
learn from them and possibly as
importantly with the network you get to
collaborate with other people rule
number 49 hire the right people we look
for compliance and willingness before
intelligence
um
so you don't look for skill you look for
someone who's I don't look for potential
I never look for potential
what do you look for then just like yes
I'm willing to do it we hired the way
the Patriots did right you know they
don't hire the best guys right
they never did it they get all the Rings
though they do okay there's three people
in charge on that team
there's not 33. it is a dictator
there's a dictator on that team
that if you study all sports I mean it's
pretty much like that too you know I
mean Portland Portland doesn't really
have that you know they he leaves Curry
alone and he leaves you know
um Durant Durant alone
and they're doing good you know I mean
it's a different style right but but um
but somebody's closer with superstars
yeah man it's got to be so hard yeah
because everyone's got a personality
yeah
but so let's see how long that Legacy
can last yeah what are they three years
now yeah so you know see if they tear
themselves apart but I know that New
England Patriots thing works
consistently there's an owner he's not
involved
this guy Bill runs the deal yeah
and then and then Bill gives the ball to
Brady and says it's a good deal yeah you
know
so uh they hired they they they they
they
hire from the lower half of the draft
they don't overpay for anybody
and if and if you don't comply you're
looking off the team they're going to
win without a great person
I like that I'm rule number 50 the last
one for a very special bonus clip is
always hustle dude I'm in the desert
right now doing deals okay I'm in
literally look
what's the difference 141 million or
140. million dollars on 140 million
dollars let's just do this thing and get
it done I'm out here in the desert how
hot is it out here
in the moment sir I'll say about 100
let me just get my it's a cool winter
day it's a cool
it's 106 degrees out here dude look look
at you jacking me around about what a
million dollars let's do the deal let's
do the damn deal just say yes to me
I don't want to talk to you about
execution and management and business
planning and culture I want to talk to
you about money because money we believe
is the number one problem in your
business
it's not Mission it's not purpose it's
not all these beautiful things everybody
tells you it's not planning and
organizing I have seven businesses
there's seven little companies there's
been no plan
there's been minimal organizing
tremendous speed
tremendous speed to Market okay is one
of the things that has made us
successful but mostly in all the
businesses every business was created
around the concept
it needs to make money
[Music]
because if it doesn't make money
you'll call yourself an entrepreneur
[Music]
because you're not going to be able to
call yourself a business person
[Music]
and so this industry of entrepreneurs
that that is now so popular
I never even knew the term until like a
year and a half ago
okay before that I was in California
somebody said I was an entrepreneur uh
15 years ago I'm like well that that's
that's code for I don't have a job
okay today today look if you want to be
an entrepreneur good but really what you
want to do is evolve to being a business
person that makes money and that
provides a good living for a lot of
other people right so number one problem
in your business is employee
disengagement it is not actually money
money is their problem
employee disengagement how many of you
here own a runner Department let me see
if you run or manage more than more than
just yourself let me see a hand
how many of you here run or manage a
household
okay good well if you can't manage the
household
by the way you have disengagement at a
household level would you agree husband
and wife are disengaged
one's doing their own plan this one's
doing their plan fifty percent of those
marriages are going to fail okay that's
what they say they're going to divorce
truth is way more than 50 fail people
should not be looking at the divorce
rate they should be looking at the
failure rate because you made it this
far in a video I want to celebrate you
most people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome if you want to see the
one-on-one I did recently with Grant
check it out right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there true wealth
cannot be created working it can only be
created and best you know is completely
invest
he has no cash and no houses